[Música]
de entre todas las del mundo hay una
jurisdicción que está siguiendo con
especial atención lo que acontece en
Ucrania cada minuto cada día Esa no es
otra que Taiwán una isla que parece
estar acumulando todas las papeletas
para convertirse en la siguiente
protagonista de una gran crisis
internacional con la protección de
Estados Unidos desde hace más de 70 años
Taiwán ha vivido al margen del régimen
chino pero siempre con La amenaza
latente de que finalmente un buen día
Pekín intente invadir la isla por
supuesto esta posibilidad podría
desencadenar un conflicto que iría mucho
más allá de un choque armado a escala
regional sería la primera vez desde la
guerra de Vietnam en la que
potencialmente Estados Unidos y China
podrían enfrentarse en un teatro de
operaciones O al menos Esa es la
impresión habitual que tenemos aunque
solo sea por declaraciones como estas
[Música]
La pregunta es qué podría ocurrir si
finalmente se desata el conflicto en
Taiwán lograría china hacerse con el
control de esta Isla qué dicen la
simulaciones de guerra que se han
realizado Pues bien arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os hemos hablado un montón de veces
sobre ello la situación de Taiwán es una
de las más ambiguas de la política
internacional especialmente porque la
soberanía de esta Isla ha sufrido
constantes cambios por ejemplo y esto
puede que te sorprenda cuando terminó la
guerra sino japonesa de 1895 el Imperio
Ching le cedió la isla con carácter
Perpetuo a Japón es decir que
formalmente la isla de formosa Taiwán
Dejó de ser China para siempre o al
menos eso fue lo que se acordó Durante
los siguientes 50 años esta Isla formó
parte del imperio de Japón Claro que la
derrota de Tokio en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial volvió a provocar un giro en los
acontecimientos La Isla pasó a formar
parte de nuevo de la entonces República
de China un país gobernado por una
dictadura militar Y en cierta forma
alineado con Estados Unidos sin embargo
cuando la revolución de Mahone y
Compañía tuvo éxito en 1949 el régimen
autoritario de la República de China se
exilió a Taiwán desde entonces La Isla
ha sido considerada por Pekín como una
especie de provincia Rebelde una isla
que es completamente Autónoma y que
funciona en la práctica como un país
soberano pero que sin embargo nunca ha
podido declarar su independencia
[Música]
primero porque su gobierno se
consideraba el gobierno legítimo de
China y más tarde porque Pekín ha dicho
hasta la saciedad una y otra y otra vez
que cualquier declaración de
Independencia será considerado como un
acto de guerra y así de esta forma se ha
ido moldeando un país que ha
experimentado durante las últimas
décadas un importante éxito económico
tecnológico y también democrático en
términos políticos y sociales Taiwán se
ha convertido en el territorio más libre
de todo el continente asiático El
problema es que la Patito de China se
está volviendo cada vez más y más grande
y queridos amigos amigas Si algo nos ha
cuando la Guerra de Ucrania es que las
exigencias territoriales de las grandes
potencias vuelven a ser un escenario
factible para el conflicto militar Y
aquí tenemos que recordar que dentro de
las hipótesis de un conflicto bélico
entre Estados Unidos y china en Taiwán
ambos bandos mantienen una visión
completamente distinta de la situación
lo que nos revela algunas claves que
tenemos que tener en cuenta
[Música]
para Pekín el problema de Taiwán es algo
estrictamente doméstico como la isla
pertenecía a la República de China y la
revolución de Mao hizo que esta fuera
sustituida por el actual régimen
comunista la República popular China
desde su punto de vista the one es una
provincia china que tiene de facto un
grado de autonomía especial es decir que
el gobierno de shijing considera que
cualquier operación militar no sería un
choque entre países sino un hecho
correspondiente al orden territorial
interno de China y ojo porque esta
posición es lo que explica la creciente
beligerancia de Pekín hacia cualquier
intromisión extranjera en la isla lo ven
como una especie de humillación una
sensación que ha sido reforzada por años
de propaganda comunista 9 de octubre de
2021 si promete la reunificación con
Taiwán en cambio por su parte Estados
Unidos mantiene un compromiso con Taiwán
que no es del todo compatible con esta
posición en la ley de relaciones de
Taiwán promulgada el 10 de Abril de 1979
los Estados Unidos adquirieron un
compromiso inquebrantable con este
territorio Estados Unidos pondrá a
disposición de Taiwán los artículos de
defensa y los servicios de defensa en la
cantidad que sea necesaria para permitir
que Taiwán mantenga suficientes
capacidades de autodefensa sección 3 de
la líder relaciones de Taiwán es decir
la ley lo deja bien claro Taiwán tiene
que poder defenderse de cualquier
intento de agresión y Estados Unidos es
el responsable de que esa situación se
produzca De hecho no parece que tenga
mucho sentido hablar de la defensa de
Taiwán si no es con Estados Unidos por
qué pues fijaos
David contra Goliat
la primera pregunta que tenemos que
responder es si china finalmente decide
invadirte igual Qué países participarían
en el conflicto y ojo Porque aquí es
donde entra en juego el punto clave de
la diplomacia norteamericana la conocida
como ambigüedad estratégica durante años
al menos oficialmente Washington no ha
dejado nunca Claro si intervendría o no
en este posible conflicto y no lo he
hecho para crear una doble visualización
veréis por un lado la amenazada latente
de la intervención de los Estados Unidos
podría evitar que china decida invadir
La Isla Pero por otro lado la
incertidumbre tampoco le permite type y
ser excesivamente agresivo por ejemplo
declarando su independencia este es el
enfoque que es algo muchos analistas ha
conseguido mantener la paz durante
décadas sin embargo las cosas están
evolucionando el ejército chino cada vez
está más y más preparado Y qué queréis
que os diga si algo ha dejado claro la
Guerra de Ucrania es que todo esto de la
ambigüedad estratégica podría terminar
siendo la excusa Perfecta de simpáñen
para lanzarse a por su presa me explico
si en un momento determinado Los Altos
gerifaltes chinos Pensarán que Unidos
podría no acudir al rescate de Taiwán y
conformarse por ejemplo con la
aplicación de sanciones entonces esa
podría ser la mejor pólvora para
desencadenar una invasión Es algo
similar a lo que ya ocurrió con la
invasión rusa en Ucrania Putin y su
entorno del creming consideraron que a
la hora de la verdad bueno que nadie
movería un dedo por gif Y eso eso es
exactamente lo que explica porque Joe
bidensa confundido intencionadamente no
una ni dos sino tres veces dejando Claro
que Estados Unidos sí que acudiría El
auxilio de su Aliado fijaos
es decir Washington no ha cambiado su
postura formal pero el presidente ha
querido dejar Clara la posición real de
la Casa Blanca quizás no sé tenga mucho
que ver que la industria avanzada de
semiconductores ha hecho de Taiwán un
enclave absolutamente estratégico para
Estados Unidos las empresas
norteamericanas la tecnología
norteamericana y no importa si hablamos
de la Inteligencia artificial de Amazon
o del f-35 todos necesitan los chips
fabricados por tsmc no sé seguro que eso
ha apoyado más la determinación de
Washington Pero por qué la posición de
la potencia norteamericana resulta tan
importante Pues básicamente porque la
potencia norteamericana es la única baza
que hoy por hoy tiene taipei por qué
pues fijaos
[Música]
amigos la descorrelación de fuerzas
entre Taiwán y la República popular
china no ha dejado de crecer con el paso
del tiempo sí tradicionalmente las
fuerzas armadas chinas han sido un
ejército mal equipado o mal entrenado y
con pobres capacidades hoy las
situaciones muy pero que muy diferentes
la República popular china está haciendo
un enorme esfuerzo por mejorar sus
capacidades militares lo que incluye la
botadura de seis nuevos portaaviones
cazas de quinta generación nuevas
capacidades anfibias y miles y miles de
misiles apuntando hacia Taiwán vale Es
cierto que Taiwán concentra su gasto
militar en la protección de un
territorio mucho menor unos 36.000
kilómetros cuadrados frente a los más de
9 millones de China pero el gigante
asiático está orientando el grueso de
sus inversiones militares Hacia El
dominio marítimo de la región lo que
incluye por supuesto la capacidad de
invadir Taiwán de hecho la diferencia
cada vez mayor de fuerzas puede ser la
razón de que Taiwán haya reducido su
esfuerzo militar durante las últimas
décadas la idea de que una china más
abierta al mundo podría eliminar
cualquier riesgo de Invasión y de que en
última instancia todo dependerá de la
posición de Estados Unidos es Quizás lo
que explica gráficos como este
ahora Esto es algo que Podría empezar a
cambiar pero lo cierto es que si la
ayuda internacional da igual lo tendría
muy pero que muy difícil para resistir
una invasión de China 17 de junio de
2022 China vota el portaaviones más
avanzado del planeta fuera de Estados
Unidos china da un nuevo golpe militar
con su nuevo portaaviones tipo 003 15 de
abril de 2023 Taiwán muy vulnerable a un
ataque aéreo chino según documentos
filtrados los preocupantes detalles
plantean dudas sobre la capacidad de las
agencias de inteligencia estadounidenses
para detectar una invasión inminente y
sobre la capacidad de La Isla para
defenderse ahora bien supongamos que por
alfa o por Beta Al final todo se va al
traste que las cosas se descontrolan y
el conflicto estalla qué podría ocurrir
Cuál sería la correlación de fuerzas si
pondría algún contendiente con Claridad
Qué dicen los simulacros que se han
realizado Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
juegos de guerra
qué podría ocurrir si finalmente la
guerra está allá en Taiwán no es una
hipótesis tan descabellada así que en
Washington es algo que se toman muy pero
que muy en serio precisamente por eso
diversos centros de investigación y
defensa de Estados Unidos han realizado
simulaciones para conocer cómo se
desarrollaría este posible conflicto
prácticamente en todos los casos se da
por sentado que las fuerzas
norteamericanas participarían Ya que en
otras circunstancias La derrota de
Taiwán estaría servida Pues bien tomemos
por ejemplo como Punto de partida la
simulación que ha llevado a cabo el
centro de estudios estratégicos e
internacionales un importante con sede
en Washington para realizar esta
simulación se tuvieron en cuenta todas
las posibles acciones aéreas y navales Y
también todos los antecedentes
históricos con misiones anfibias desde
normandía hasta okinawa pasando por las
malvinas los resultados Pues fijaos en
la mayoría de los escenarios Estados
Unidos Taiwán y Japón lograrían derrotar
la invasión anfibia convencional de
China y manten la autonomía de Taiwán
Eso sí esta defensa tendría un alto
coste Estados Unidos y sus aliados
perderían docenas de barcos cientos de
aviones y sufrirían decenas de miles de
bajas pensad que Estados Unidos tendría
que combatir a miles de millas de
distancia contra unas fuerzas armadas
chinas que jugarían en casa por su parte
la economía de Taiwán quedaría devastada
por la destrucción de gran parte de su
infraestructura Claro que china también
sufriría grandes pérdidas y el fracaso
de la operación podría terminar
desestabilizando el gobierno del partido
comunista chino
los resultados de esta simulación
muestran que solo si Taiwán no recibe
apoyo militar directo china lograría
hacerse con el control de La Isla Eso sí
Incluso en este escenario la resistencia
taiwanesa podría alargar la invasión 70
días pero vale Ya sé lo que algunos
estaréis pensando ya están otra vez los
de visualpolitik haciendo propaganda de
la hegemonía imperialista del Águila
calva pues ni lo estamos haciendo ahora
ni lo hemos hecho nunca de hecho estos
simulacros son de todo menos alentadores
para Estados Unidos en la simulación
Incluso el mejor de los escenarios
conlleva pérdidas sumamente importantes
para Estados Unidos y Japón así como
importantes repercusiones económicas en
otras palabras da igual el resultado
nadie saldría ganando cualquier intento
chino de invadir Taiwán sería un
desastre para todas las partes pero ahí
no queda todo
los resultados de esta simulación
alertan de tres riesgos más que posibles
primero los daños provocados por ataques
cibernéticos podrían causar importantes
daños económicos y sociales en los
propios Estados Unidos segundo el daño
sufrido por las fuerzas militares
norteamericanas podría ser difícil de
reponer reconstruir la capacidad podría
llevar años mientras que china un país
dotado con una mayor capacidad
Industrial podría aprovechar este
escenario para equilibrar las tornas
sería algo así como una victoria pírrica
para Estados Unidos tercero países como
Rusia Corea del Norte o Irán podrían
aprovechar esa distracción y merma de
recursos de Estados Unidos para acelerar
sus agendas políticas es decir que hoy
por hoy incluso Aunque Estados Unidos
podría evitar la anexión de Taiwán los
resultados potenciales serían muy altos
a veces en la guerra ganar no lo es todo
la historia nos deja importantes
lecciones al respecto por ejemplo en
1919 tras la firma del tratado de
Versalles el Mariscal francés Ferdinand
foich expresó su preocupación por el
resultado de la Primera Guerra Mundial
hemos firmado un armisticio de 20 años
el Mariscal consideraba que a pesar de
haber ganado la contienda Francia había
quedado gravemente diezmada y que podía
ser vulnerable ante un rearme alemán en
un plazo de tiempo no muy lejano Pues
bien los simulacros plantean que algo
muy similar podría llegar a pasar con
Estados Unidos
[Música]
y ojo que aquí no queda todo las
derivadas de este asunto pueden llegar a
ser mucho más complejas incluso sin que
estalle la guerra tal y como todos la
concebimos en enero de 2022 otro cintank
el Center For a New American Security
hizo una simulación para conocer qué
podría ocurrir con la industria de los
semiconductores los resultados no fueron
optimistas Asimismo en junio de 2022
este mismo cintank realizó también una
simulación sobre cómo podría
desencadenarse la guerra en este caso
justo antes de la invasión El dilema que
le surgía a Pekín era si concentrarse
exclusivamente en Taiwán y evitar atacar
a las fuerzas de Estados Unidos con la
esperanza de que esta se mantuvieran al
margen o por contra atacar a los
norteamericanos para obtener ventaja
militar e intentar forzar una
negociación lo curioso es que según esta
simulación al final china optaría por
atacar a Taiwán en paralelo a una
ofensiva sobre la flota y las bases
norteamericanas más próximas y sabéis
que se sabe que el ejército chino está
entrenándose para atacar la flota
norteamericana por ejemplo tal y como
podéis ver en estas imágenes tomadas en
un desierto de la provincia de shinchán
los chinos están utilizando para sus
entrenamientos militares con misiles
objetivos que recrean los portaaviones
de la clase nimits y otros buques de
guerra de Estados Unidos un aviso a
navegantes
incluso según los simulacros que estamos
comentando una de las opciones que
tendría china sería evitar atacar con
misiles Taiwán para no dañar gravemente
su industria tecnológica y en su lugar
detonar un artefacto nuclear en el
Pacífico para intimidar a los
norteamericanos y forzar negociaciones
esto explicaría también la recientes
prisas que siguen parece tener por
construir muchas más armas nucleares es
decir si realmente están dispuestos a
emplear esa amenaza para que esta sea
creíble y pueda surtir efecto tiene que
estar respaldada por la mayor fuerza
posible china ya supera Estados Unidos
en capacidad ofensiva nuclear terrestre
china Ya tiene más lanzadores de misiles
nucleares desde tierra que los Estados
Unidos Aunque todavía no lo supera en
número total de cabezas nucleares Es
probable que china tenga 1500 cabezas
nucleares en 2035 Pentágono queridos
amigos de visualpolitik en general el
resultado de la mayor parte de la
simulaciones que se han realizado es que
Estados Unidos superaría militarmente a
China Pero eso sí lo haría pagando un
precio excesivamente alto por no estar
suficientemente preparados y sabéis que
aquí es donde el trabajo del secretario
de estado Anthony blinken y el
Secretario de Defensa Louis Austin de
impulsar los acuerdos de defensa en la
región cobran todo el sentido del mundo
es posible que la mejor y tal vez única
forma efectiva de disuadir a China es
que Estados Unidos se asegurara el apoyo
de muchos más contendientes Japón Corea
del Sur Australia Reino Unido etcétera
etcétera En otras palabras que puede que
en este caso la sola carta de Estados
Unidos ya no sea suficiente disuasión
para China y esto nos lleva directamente
a otra pregunta qué hemos aprendido Y
qué no hemos aprendido de la experiencia
de Ucrania
la no lección de la Victoria
insuficiente
queridos amigos de visualpolitik un
problema que tiene la defensa de Taiwán
es que intentar replicar lo que se ha
hecho en Ucrania para evitar la
intervención de tropas extranjeras
podrían no ser viable la situación
geográfica es completamente diferente
creo que en estos mapas Vais a poder ver
las diferencias perfectamente en la
Guerra de Ucrania tanto Estados Unidos
como el resto de aliados de la otan han
enviado enormes cantidades de equipos y
de suministros vía terrestre algo que
Taiwán sería totalmente imposible por su
condición insular en este caso china
además podría aislar La Isla durante
semanas e incluso meses de hecho el
pasado 8 de abril durante al menos tres
días las fuerzas armadas chinas
ensayaron Cómo realizar un cerco total
sobre Taiwán para cortar así cualquier
posibilidad de que Estados Unidos pues
pudiera reabastecer a las fuerzas de tu
defensa locales en caso de conflicto y
es una estrategia que se ve reforzado
por cosas como esta fijaos 22 de agosto
de 2022 los planes actuales de
adquisiciones y adquisición revelan que
en 10 años Estados Unidos no tendrá
significativamente más fuerzas para
desplegar en la región de las que tiene
ahora la marina de los Estados Unidos
modernizando pero no tendrá su flota
planificada de entre 450 y 500 barcos
hasta 2045 un tamaño de flota que china
tendrá en solo 10 años por eso cualquier
intento de defender Taiwán tiene que
empezar porque la isla esté preparada
para repeler una invasión en cualquier
momento lo que incluye tener toda la
munición y todos los suministros
necesarios como para resistir
por su parte Estados Unidos tiene que
tener la capacidad de desplegar
rápidamente tropas y equipos en Taiwán o
en el entorno de Taiwán todo esto que os
estamos contando es el motivo por el que
Taiwán se está convirtiendo en la
prioridad número uno para los
responsables de la seguridad y la
defensa no solo del gobierno sino
también del Congreso de Estados Unidos
20 de abril de 2023 el juego de guerra
de esta Taiwán muestra la necesidad de
una acción decisiva para aumentar el
armamento un guerra del Congreso
estadounidense que simulaba una invasión
China de Taiwán mostró la necesidad de
armar a la isla hasta los dientes
Estados Unidos debe aumentar la
producción de misiles de largo alcance y
las empresas deben prepararse para las
consecuencias económicas Pero de todo
esto del posible plan para intentar
defenderse de China ya os hemos hablado
aquí en visualpolitik en varios vídeos
que os dejo en la descripción queridos
amigos amigas la Guerra de Ucrania nos
ha demostrado dos cosas que lo
impensable perfectamente es posible y
que los tiempos de los grandes choques
militares todavía no han pasado a la
historia El objetivo de Estados Unidos
es Buscar la forma de preservar la
independencia de Taiwán y en general la
superioridad militar y económica de los
países libres respecto a cualquier
autocracia del mundo pero para recabar
ese objetivo recabar cada vez más apoyos
y aliados puede ser algo absolutamente
indispensable dicho esto La pregunta es
realmente se puede salvaguardar la
independencia de facto de Taiwán estará
china dispuesta a tomar las armas algún
día logrará Estados Unidos construir una
gran coalición de países libres
dispuestos a defender su libertad
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y hablamos de bate Y como siempre si
este vídeo se ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
si es que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez
más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]